[Music]
it is so uncommon to find reason and
sentiment with Noble and delicate
affections in a man whom nature as it
were could not make up and who in size
has the appearance of a child persuaded
nobody would even take the trouble to
cast an eye upon these Memoirs I began
to commit to paper some of the principal
events of My Life by way of memorandums
for my own use only to be reminded of
the different situations I had been in
to call to my memory scenes too
interesting emotions too strong to die
in
Oblivion the reflections which I shall
make can be interesting only to those
who Delight in following nature through
all her varieties and who consequently
may be curious to see a being like me
assimilate himself to creatures of a
common size those however would be much
mistaken Who Would Imagine That seduced
by the repeated kindness bestowed on me
or wholly devoted to the pleasures
afforded me I did not sometimes labor
under painful
feelings or that I could always be
unconscious of being upon the whole only
looked upon by others as a doll a little
more perfect it is true and better
organized than they commonly are but
however only as an animated
toy it was easy to judge from the very
instant of my birth that I should be
extremely short being at the time I was
only 8 in yet not withstanding this
diminutive proportion I was neither weak
nor puny on the contrary I walked and
was able to speak about the same age
common to other infants and my growth
was progressively as follows at one year
I was 1 1 in at 10 2T and at 30 3'
3 this is the size at which I remained
fixed by which the assertion of some
naturalists proved false that dwarves
grow during all their
lifetime I had scarcely ented my ninth
year when my father died and left my
mother with six children a circumstance
to which I am indebted for the part I
have since acted in the world had he not
died I undoubtedly should have lived
obscure and unknown in a province in
Russian Poland and perhaps I would have
been happier
[Music]
Europe is the second smallest continent
in the world just ahead of Australia but
has had an outsized impact on the earth
For Better or Worse my recommendation
this week on curiosity stream is the
Fantastic in-depth documentary The Story
of Europe which takes you on a journey
from distant Rome to the precarious
alliances of the present day and that's
just one of curiosity streams thousand
thousand of documentaries to choose from
it's like a huge Netflix for factual
content this video has been sponsored by
curiosity stream and it's a bargain with
packages as low as $5 a month with a
wide range of exclusive documentaries
with new shows popping up every week and
it's super easy to use you can watch
them on your phone TV or laptop so head
over to curiositystream.com voices of
the past or scan the QR code for
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series and
for our fans use promo code voices of
the past and you'll save 25% off thanks
to curiosity stream for supporting
educational content on
YouTube a friend of my mother the
Countess Huma showed me much affection
and often had solicited my parents to
commit my education to her care my
mother consented not without tears to
part with me and the took me to her
estate the Countess Huma seemed
Overjoyed at my consent I'm very glad
said she my dear zuu for so they called
me to see you have no reluctance to come
and live with
me after some days of very fatiguing
travel we reached Vienna where the
report of our arrival was no sooner
spread than we were visited and
entertained with utmost eagerness soon
after we had the honor to be presented
to her Imperial Majesty the queen of
Hungary who graciously said that I
exceeded by far all that she had heard
that I was one of the most astonishing
things she'd ever seen the empress near
whom I stood asked me how the King of
Prussia was looked upon in Poland and
what idea I entertained of that Prince
Madam I answered I have not the honor to
know him but were I in his place instead
of losing my time in waging a useless
war against you I would come to Vienna
and pay my respects to you deeming it a
thousand times more glorious to gain
your esteem and friendship than to
obtain the most complete victories over
your troops her Imperial Majesty seemed
much pleased at my reply and hugged me
in her
arms another time I had performed a
Polish dance in her presence and she
took me on her lap and after having much
caressed me she wished to know what I
found at Vienna most curious and
interesting I answered I had seen there
many things worthy of a traveler's
admiration but nothing seemed to me so
extraordinary as what I beheld at that
very moment and what is it said her
majesty it is I replied to see so little
a man on the lap of so great a woman
this answer gained me new
caresses I should be guilty of
ingratitude where I silent on the
kindness of his Excellency the prince
cits this great man who at the time was
ruling as he still does all the Affairs
of the German Empire yet could still
find time to spend on small objects and
I may say that the marks of friendship
and interest he honored me with would
have raised many jealousies had not my
size and mode of existence put me out of
the common line he called me his little
friend pretending that my conversation
both amused and interested him though I
do remember among other things that one
day in the apartment of my benefactors
when sitting in a corner at a little
distance and apparently paying no
attention to the conversation I heard
they were speaking of me one of the
company having put the question whether
dwarves possess the faculty of
procreating another advance that if they
have it their children would grow to the
common size she added that she had often
revolved in her own mind how pleasant it
would be to join these two little
creatures that the result might decide
the
question spare my readers the
particulars of that conversation which
was carried very far and only
interrupted by my weeping bitterly I
thought I had to conclude not only that
they believed themselves entitled to
dispose of me without my advice but even
looked upon me as being merely physical
without morality on whom they might try
experiments of every kind somebody in
the company perceiving my grief wished
to know the cause of it which I
persisted in concealing at length
arriving at Munich we were most
graciously welcomed by his electoral
highness and it seemed I excited no less
curiosity there than in Vienna we left
that place to repair to lunaville where
stanislav Linsky the titular king of
Poland held his court with this Prince
lived the famous Bebe till then
considered as the most extraordinary
dwarf that ever was seen who was indeed
of a perfect ly proportioned shape with
very pleasing features but who I'm sorry
to say it for the honor of our species
had both in his mind in way of thinking
all the defects commonly attributed to
us he was at that time about 30 his
height 28 in and when measured it
appeared that I was much shorter being
no more than 2' 4 in at the time at our
first meeting he showed much fondness
and friendship towards me but when he
perceived that I preferred the company
and conversation of sensible people to
his own and above all when he saw that
the king took pleasure in my company he
conceived against me the most violent
jealousy and hatred one day we were both
in the apartment of his majesty this
Prince having much caressed me and asked
several questions to which I gave
satisfactory answers seemed pleased with
my replies and testified his pleasure
then addressing Bebe saying to him you
see Bebe what a difference there is
between juu and you he is amiable
cheerful entertaining and full of
knowledge whereas you are but a little
machine at these words I saw Fury
Sparkle in his eyes he answered nothing
but his countenance and blush proved
enough that he was violently
agitated a moment after the king being
gone to his closet Bebe availed himself
of that instant to execute his
revengeful project and slightly
approaching seized me by the waist and
endeavored to push me Into the Fire
luckily I laid hold with both hands on
an iron hook and thus I prevented this
wicked design the noise I made in
defending myself brought back the king
who came to my assistance and saved me
from that imminent danger he afterwards
called for his servants put Bebe into
their hands and B them inflict on him a
corporal punishment and ordered him
never to appear in his presence
[Music]
anymore in vain did I inter proed on
behalf of the unhappy Bebe but I could
not save him the first part of his
sentence and as for the other his
majesty did consent to revoke it upon
condition he should beg my pardon Bebe
with much reluctance submitted to this
humiliation he fell sick a short time
after and
died everybody attributed his death to
the jealousy I sincerely pied him I
would not have related this circumstance
but to remark that the smallness of our
St
does not prevent us from experiencing
the power of the
passions my return to my native country
made much
noise I had not yet been seen in the
capital but was preceded by the
reputation I had acquired in my travels
besides I had improved during my stay in
foreign countries and as Paris had given
me somewhat of the easy politeness which
Graces manners I was happy to perceive
that many persons by whom first I was
looked upon only as an object of me
curiosity sought my company because they
took pleasure in my conversation
emboldened by this notice and willing to
enlarge the circle of my acquaintance I
cultivated friendships with several
young gentlemen of my age and women in
my eyes had taken quite a new form they
excited my admiration my Sensibility
my
[Music]
desires it was sufficient to be a woman
I was fond of the sex without choice or
distinction I Lov them all in a word at
the age of 25 I was like the other young
Lads at 15 these emotions quite new to
me had their charms and perhaps I had
been happier if I could have been
contented with experiencing them without
seeking how to gratify desires
unhappily such a resistance is not in
the nature of man pressed by the warmth
of my Constitution I wish to fix my
views upon a particular object how much
was my mind mortified on reflecting upon
my stature which I considered as an
insurmountable object to the happiness I
longed for the most reserved women take
me upon their lap they embrace me they
bestow upon me the most tender caresses
they use me like only a child how can I
hazard in such circumstances a
declaration at which they will only
laugh whilst I shall remain covered with
eternal ridicule the farther I was from
having the common size of other men the
more lively I wished that difference
might be forgotten and that I might be
treated like them but experience has
taught me that I thought as a child I
was ignorant of the effect such
wonderful things may produce above all I
knew not forgive me how far women might
be led by
[Music]
curiosity there was then at Warsaw among
the French comedians an actress highly
distinguished for her talents a certain
mixture of tenderness and vivacity
rendered her infinitely interesting and
though not regularly handsome she
possessed all that was requisite to
please and
seduce I always saw her with pleasure
and openly preferred her to all others
one night night when she had made me a
most particular impression on going out
of the playhouse I met with one of my
friends who confessed that he was going
to Su a little at precisely her address
ah I exclaimed with emotion are you
acquainted with her so may you be
answered my giddy young friend I will
introduce you to her and you may be sure
to be well received this offer I
accepted with transport and the very
next day I was introduced and welcomed
in a manner equal to that I had been
made to hope this visit passed away
merrily and when I retired she most
earnestly invited me often to repeat it
but our diance did not last
long I was sincere in my attachment and
imagining myself beloved she made me
happy therefore how great must be my
astonishment when one day on meeting by
Chance the very same young man who had
introduced me to her I was told that my
little Intrigue was known to everybody
and spoken of publicly that they
bantered my discretion and she whom I
thought the most interested in secrecy
did not mind to openly laugh at my
passion and eagerness at the tumultuous
emotions she had excited in me that she
even gloried in it this discovery sunk
me down and humbled my pride I Thought I
Loved sincerely I had hoped to to be
sincerely beloved and it was not without
extreme grief I saw the veil fall and my
illusion
[Music]
dispelled however I am now entering into
the particulars of events which I shall
always regard as the most interesting
Epoch of My Life The Bounty of my
benefactor the Countess seemed likely
forever to secure me from want I did not
foresee the probability of ever being
deprived of her friendship I was
caressed fondled and cherished but I
knew not my own heart and all those fine
expectations vanished from the moment I
beheld a young female whom my
benefactress had taken into her house
such as I have described was the young
is Alina's Beauty which struck me at
first sight and subdued my heart but if
the impression of the moment was deep
and indelible conceive what new Force
must have been given to my feelings when
by living in the same house I had daily
opportunities of seeing her and of
enjoying the pleasure of her Lively
conversation I perceived in her all the
symptoms of mutual affection and proud
of the love with which I was conscious
she regarded me I determined not to give
up in my
Enterprise but these raptures were soon
interrupted by the
Countess she was fully informed of and
saw with concern my affection for is Ina
she became Furious and setting me at
Liberty declared I had only to choose
either to renounce my love for isolina
or to quit her house
immediately I preferred the latter
alternative it is true that I sacrificed
to this marriage the happiness ease and
Tranquility I had before it has been to
me the source of a thousand worries
respecting the subsist of is Alina and
myself for the future yet the enjoyment
that I have derived from it has taught
me nothing in this world is preferable
to the satisfaction of pouring our
distresses and our fears into the bosom
of a friend so true so dear and so
closely United whose tender and feeling
Soul relieves our pains by sharing
them I should have been happy in my new
state if it had been possible to solely
mind the present without casting an eye
on the future and mine and isel's
maintenance it was needful to take some
step but the choice was so much the more
difficult as having received no other
education but such as was analogous to
my size and the station which the
extreme Bounty of the Countess seemed to
have ascribed to me I possessed at most
a few agreeable talents which would not
offer me any resource in this perplexity
my protectors were the first who
suggested to me the idea of a second
Journey the prince Chamberlain
especially seconded this project he
intimated to me that having been kindly
received in the principal courts of
Europe years before they would see me
again with the same pleasure and on
knowing that I was a father create
interest and in a decent manner procure
me the means of leading at my return a
peaceful and tranquil life
seduced by such a dazzling Prospect I
entirely gave myself up to this idea I
resolved to leave Vienna being supplied
with letters of recommendation to many
princes of Germany and to the courts of
other
kingdoms amongst other places which I at
this time visited was asan the principal
city of Asiatic Russia which is situated
at the mouth of the vulgar accordingly
being provided with letters of
recommendation I set out for Kazan also
a great City perceiving that the place
afforded me the prospect of a good
benefit I began to employ my time in
arranging the preparation for
concert my concert favored with the
patronage of such great and generous
personages more than answered my most
sanguin expectations I then felt a
desire to visit the desolate country of
Nova Z
Mr Vitz did not approve of this voyage
and gave me to understand that no
concert could be given there but finding
me quite determined and having some
business there himself he kindly offered
to take charge of me we sailed together
over the White Sea and landed safely at
Nova
Zambia I afterwards regretted that I had
not listened to the advice of my friend
Mr Vitz as I found it was vain to expect
any kind of benefit and perceived no
objects that could gratify y the eye of
a traveler the whole country presented
the appearance of desolation and
distress for which however we ought not
to blame nature which is always perfect
in her operations but here her Noble
principles had been quite destroyed this
unfortunate corner of the globe
presented the most dismal appearance the
natives are chiefly Savages and as might
naturally be expected rude as their
native climate their size is in general
diminutive and their strength may be
easily managed the following
circumstance introduced me to their
acquaintance it happened that we were
traveling in a sledge to visit some
mountains of a prodigious height which
seem to hang in the air and cannot be
looked upon without horror and which are
inhabited by beasts of a Monumental
size at this time the Savages were
hunting these animals for the sake of
their skins with which as they have no
money in that country they pay their
taxes to the Emperor of Russia I was
spotted by some of them who approached
and viewed me with such looks of
surprise that I doubt not I became the
principal topic of their conversation
the third day after this they surrounded
our house in great numbers and
dispatched a messenger to inform us that
if I did not come out and see them they
would pull down the whole house in order
to prevent the Mischief these Savages
intended me I made my appearance before
them I was probably indebted for my
safety to the smallness of my size as
soon as their astonishment had ceased I
observed that they assumed a singular
posture and lifted up their hands and
eyes to the sky as if in worship of the
sun my curiosity induced me to ask the
reason of this Behavior they answered me
with great calmness that they were
giving thanks to the son for allowing
them to find such a man as me as they
had seen many people of various sizes
but never beheld anything like mine
I at the same time proceeded for their
Amusement to play some tunes on my
guitar with which they were highly
delighted having never before seen or
heard that instrument I please them so
much that I think I may flatter myself
and say that I won their
hearts Savages as they were a heart
atoned for many
defects I've already observed that his
Excellency Sir Robert Murray Keith had
prevailed upon me to visit England by
having assured me a thousand times that
I could not fail of making a brilliant
fortune in a country where generosity
and greatness of Soul are reckoned among
the most characteristic Virtues Of The
Nation as I possessed letters of
recommendation to several of the first
nobility in the Kingdom no time was to
be lost in making my application
particularly to their Graces the Duke
and Duchess of Devonshire The Duchess of
Devonshire and her whole family took the
most Lively interest interest in all
that concerned me conscious that my
situation was beneath my birth education
and sentiments she kindly recommended me
to all her acquaintances in the number
of whom I must distinguish the Countess
of egrant who being informed that
mention had been made of me at court
stuffed one of my shoes with cotton and
sent it to the queen this excited their
curiosity and their majesties
condescended to appoint a day for me to
wait on them the king and all the royal
family were present his majesty desired
me to sit down and put several questions
to me the conversation was often
interrupted by the witty and agreeable
sallyes of his Royal Highness the Prince
of Wales I had the honor of remaining 4
hours with their majesties who I flatter
myself were pleased with my efforts to
entertain them these efforts were
however nearly fatal to me for I
returned with a fever and the very next
day I was dangerously
ill
various rumors were at that time
circulated respecting my visit to court
and it was mentioned in some newspapers
that I had received a considerable sum
of money from their majesties these
reports were as usual founded on
conjecture only for had they the least
foundation in truth I would not have
admitted to mention the particulars as I
consider it my duty to declare all the
favors I have been indulged with the
fact is that his majesty vouched to
treat me as a Polish gentleman s Keith
had given me many letters for his
friends in England and assured me a
thousand times that I could not fail to
make a splendid Fortune here so positive
were his feelings for the country but he
never declared to me that I must exhibit
myself I was advised to give a concert
and afterwards I was prevailed upon to
make an exhibition of myself the pre of
want and hope of success overcame all
those emotions in my heart and made the
expedient seem so
[Music]
shocking now that I was left to my
solitary Reflections on the pilgrimage
in which I was engaged so severely did I
feel the disappointments I had
experienced that I could not help
thinking it was well that Providence had
blessed me with such a firm
determination to act like an upright man
as the world afforded so strong an
inducement to Travelers like myself to
better their circumstances by acting
like a
Nave in the midst of these conflicting
thoughts and mournful Reflections a
black cat made his appearance by
entering my room this Interruption to my
revery gave me a new turn of thinking I
couldn't help admiring the confidence of
this creature in putting his trust in me
I had no objection to appoint him curate
of my parish and by so doing he became
my constant visitor about this time a
lady of rank honored me with a visit who
immediately perceived the black cat
sitting on the sofa she strongly
expressed her admiration of this natural
beauty and touching him with a hand as
white as snow made him proudly stretch
himself with joy in this position he
appeared 2 ft long and proportionately
fat as he enjoyed good living in fact
she was the Ed with him beyond measure
and promised to procure me a number of
customers to see him she kept her word
and in a few days I found my room rather
too small to contain so numerous a
company amongst this crowd of amateurs I
met with a gentleman who was closely
inquisitive about the place of his birth
and although I possessed no information
at this point I yet conferred on him the
honor of being a native of Prussia born
at Berlin and Son of the favorite cat of
Frederick the Great
I found this Rod had artificial fly
catch fish from the deepest Rivers his
reputation soon spread he derived an
additional luster from Noble origin and
rapidly became a favorite of the whole
town this favorable circumstance
suggested to me a new project and I wish
to seize the moment of this enthusiasm
and Rapture of the public and give him
some lessons in tricks for said I when I
consider the natural sharpness of such
animals and their docil when young I may
expect that with such advantages he will
become as celebrated as the Learned Pig
so much admired in England but however
well digested this plan might have been
I could not arrive at such a degree of
perfection in it as to procure any
solution to my situation for my pupil
was found to be of a voracious
disposition with a treacherous and
ambitious design of improving his manner
of living He slightly insinuated himself
self into the room where some Canary
birds were kept and committed murder
with such a cruel mind and premeditated
barbarity that it was almost impossible
to find any remains of
them the cat being found guilty of this
heinous crime had sentence passed on him
by his own Master to be
[Music]
hanged I gave my first concert by the
advice of their Graces the Duke and
Duchess of Devonshire had the enthusiasm
continued some concerts given now and
then would have placed Me Above want
this however was not the case for having
attempted to give another a few weeks
after in the same place the receipts
scarcely cleared my
expenses however gloomy may be the
general aspect of Winter the sun
sometimes Smiles in spite of the season
resistless in the power of His
brightness the least Ray of which will
melt the frozen snow
equally cheering to me in this winter of
my fate was the appearance of the Mrs
Metar whose names I am forbid to mention
they did not approve of me giving a
concert much less of my making an
exhibition of myself their Noble Souls
reped with elevated sentiments looked
upon my exhibition with disdain and I
was therefore compelled to try some
other
plan I determined to renew my concerts
the profits of which afforded me a temp
liary
relief after many years traveling
England and Ireland I now draw near to
the conclusion of my wanding life being
arrived in that period in which I
quitted the busy stage where I had
performed in part so many tragic and
comic scenes and retired to the quiet
enjoyment away from its cares and
perplexities which had been the object
of my wishes from my earliest
days it was in the Happy Land of England
that I found this
[Music]
blessing